joining me right here uh on the front
uh of everything that we just laid out
for the nfl on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is my colleague from the nfl
media group who's just been fantastic um
covering everything in this crazy mixed
up nfl world he's tom pelicero how you
doing tom
slightly calmer than i was one week ago
at this time but we're not done yet rich
i bet i know there's still so many uh
guys out there but i'm i'm still i still
haven't turned the page as they say in
our in our business
um how did the browns get back in on
watson was it born out of mayfield
saying i want out and they decided well
uh one way to move on then uh and get
out of all this is to um is to get
watson anyway
the browns gave to sean watson 230
million reasons to choose cleveland
fully guaranteed they were told they
were out on thursday morning
they came back later on that day i was
told by somebody involved in the
situation that when sean watson went to
bed on thursday night there was maybe a
10
chance
that he was going to be a brown but he
woke up
and continued to think on the roster on
uh the general manager andrew berry
who've been so aggressive pursuing him
on the owner jimmy haslam who uh you
know really impressed him with his
knowledge of the football operation and
then there was the contract i mean rich
this is not just within the context of
deshaun watson
and the
serious allegations of sexual misconduct
that he continues to face in 22 civil
lawsuits an nfl investigation that uh
could lead to a suspension even though
he was not criminally charged
this is a
unprecedented contract
in every way so much so that
when i was talking to general managers
and other front office people and people
were reaching out directly to me
obviously there's a lot involved with
the watson situation and there were
various reasons the other teams involved
were not willing to do a contract like
this but at a very base level contracts
like this don't exist in the nfl and so
somebody i respect very much in the
league told me they just changed the
entire landscape of the economics of the
nfl because all of a sudden it's a
five-year guarantee 230 million dollars
which means that not only does watson
get paid 46 million this year but jimmy
haslam has to put a 184 million dollar
check into escrow by next march 31st to
cover the remaining guarantees
teams don't do that and now for
everybody who's got a franchise
quarterback coming up whether it is
lamar jackson who is in the midst of
talks whether it's you know guys like
joe burrow and justin herbert who are
kind of going to be coming up soon kyler
murray who wants and expects a contract
asap from the cardinals this is the new
benchmark and it's so far beyond any
other deal we've seen in terms of
guaranteed money that this has the
possibility uh to be an inflection point
and we'll see you know obviously not
everyone's going to have the leverage
from a football perspective that desean
watson did but we'll see how this now
has an impact on future contracts
because there's a lot of teams that
aren't happy about this well you should
you're right to say leverage from a
football perspective because
watson had no leverage from an outsider
football perspective and i'm sure that's
what
prospective agents are going to be
saying you know about justin herbert and
you know or anybody else burrow coming
up assuming you know they don't have any
off the field
um you know issues that that
garner uh an absurd number of civil
lawsuits that's filed against him so um
why did the brown like what due
diligence best you can tell did the
browns do
on watson where they felt comfortable
doing this knowing that they'd have to
sell it to a fan base and knowing that
watson will have to do that
personally at some point as well
i would say broadly speaking the teams
involved
in deshaud watson trade talks
did extensive background work some of
them hired uh private investigators to
go to houston um certainly getting in
touch with various people involved with
the legal process and obviously the
attorney representing the 22 women in
the civil lawsuit says that he was not
reached out to nor were his clients but
there was substantial digging that went
into this reference work um and listen i
certainly understand
the sensitivity of the matter and the
concerns that a lot of people have
about the totality of this particularly
when you're fully guaranteeing someone
230
million dollars indemnifying them
against
having to give that up is eventually
uh they are you know desean watson is
suspended by the league um but teams you
know you you aren't putting this type of
capital and this type of contract
forward if you do not have a level of
confidence not certainty but confidence
that there are not going to be
further allegations that behavior
that decision making is going to change
and that desean watson realizes that
he's going to need to
be completely on the straight and narrow
and you know re-establish himself as
they said in their statements in the
community
again i understand that that's not going
to be
enough for plenty of people and i'm
sensitive to that and i think that the
browns understand
what they were dealing with here but
again what is the goal of nfl teams it's
not to have
90 of the perfect citizens it's to win
football games like it or not that's
their job is to win football games and
make money desean watson can help the
browns do both those things
and they were willing to
take all the risk on that houston had
been carrying over the past 14 months by
keeping him on the roster uh that now
transfers to cleveland so tom tell me
what is watson's camp telling you right
because um we have not heard publicly
from desean watson
outside of an occasional i guess what
social media post
at all and so you know the void is
filled with people who feel outraged
that somebody who has these civil
lawsuits hanging over him
gets this sort of guaranteed money
before they even hear from him as to why
he deserves it or why
you know it's deserving to think he's
turned a corner or everything that has
been said about him is false
so what what are they saying about
all of this from what you hear
tom
i would say for the same reason that
john woods watson invoked the fifth
amendment in his civil deposition that
came on the same day that the grand jury
was hearing
the district attorney's findings on the
criminal side
you will it is unlikely that desean
watson is going to make substantive
statements
regarding his actions regarding any
alleged incidents regarding anything
really
prior to those civil cases also being
resolved now part of the reason
that watson and his camp have made clear
that he was not willing to settle
across the board reach a global
settlement prior to this on the simple
side
was that he wanted to not have
non-disclosure agreements in other words
he wanted to be able to comment publicly
and in turn all the women would also be
able to
uh comment publicly which is the
opposite of how this uh normally goes so
i would anticipate there's going to be a
point in time where you are going to
hear from deshaun watson where he is
going to go on the offensive as he may
have or may not have we don't know in
the most recent deposition when he did
not uh invoke the fifth amendment so
it's it's complicated on so many levels
just because you also have the nfl
investigation the nfl has spoken with a
certain number i don't know the precise
number but they have spoken with
multiple women
who were involved in the cases uh now
the criminal side of things are closed
that's when the nfl based on its
investigatory process
gathers more information so they don't
interfere in any criminal investigations
but so evidence
um you know whatever it might be that
the nfl now is trying to get that into
their hands
and their disciplinary decision is going
to be
on a different standard under the
personal conduct policy so one side of
this with the grand jury not criminally
charging deshaun watson obviously is
over for now but the civil suits the nfl
investigation those are still moving and
so it doesn't really benefit desean
watson to say a great deal publicly
right now particularly when amidst as
you mentioned rich the silence the
relative silence that he's had for a
long period of time came out with him on
the other side going a place where he
gets to play with a really good team and
make 230 million dollars fully
guaranteed over the next five years tom
palisaro nfl media group colleague of
mine right here on the rich eisen show
what what about baker now let's talk
about the plan
for him before we get to some other
team's plan b's now that they've lost on
out on watson what do you got for me on
baker
well baker wanted the fresh start and he
is now going to get it the complicating
factors are you've got a player who's
fully guaranteed over 18.8 million
dollars next season
and is coming off a season where he was
really hurt he played hurt the entire
season and didn't play nearly to the
level that he had
back in 2020 when the browns went to the
playoffs and won their first playoff
game in 26 years uh this may be a
situation where the browns need to eat
some money in order to get value it
sounds like the price at least out of
the gate was roughly what the 49ers want
for jimmy garoppolo what the falcons
initially wanted for matt ryan most of
these guys the price starts out as a
second round pick and an additional pick
i i find it hard to believe not
impossible but hard to believe that the
browns are going to get that price
because also the entire league knows
that they have to trade baker mayfield
that there's no path forward for him uh
on the roster at this point it's an
interesting spot because so you know
early on i think in this offseason it
was a seller's market when you looked at
the names and the vacancies now you can
argue it's a buyer's market because for
a team like the colts somebody garoppolo
has got to go somewhere matt ryan may
have to go somewhere baker mayfield
definitely has to go somewhere marcus
mariota is still looking for a job andy
dalton is looking for a job james
winston all likely to end up back in new
orleans but for the moment he remains a
free agent you don't need to jump out
and get the one guy there's a bunch of
people available and meanwhile these
teams are looking at
the the selling teams are looking at the
vacancies and seeing fewer and fewer
they may become more motivated to deal
somebody sooner than later so where
baker ends up
that's to be determined i know that he
would like to end up with the colts
but the colts have as i mentioned a
variety of different options on the
table i'll be fascinated to see where
baker lands and how he plays because
again we got the best of baker mayfield
in 2020 last year was plainly not his
best and he was playing through multiple
significant injuries
where his career goes from here all i
know is baker mayfield has always played
his best when he feels like he's been
slighted when he's got that edge and
that chip on his shoulder and he
absolutely is going to have it now rich
so
is seattle in on this
at all
seattle's in an interesting spot because
they traded for a quarterback or
received a quarterback in the russell
wilson trade who they liked a lot coming
out drew locke who's he's really
athletic and he's tall and he's got a
cannon arm
you know he's been inconsistent but was
playing in an offense that probably was
not best suited to his strengths or the
strengths of the
uh the players around him in denver so
they envisioned him at least competing
for the job but you know john schneider
the general manager in seattle's you
know one of those guys who's always
going to be in on every deal absolutely
i think that another quarterback trade
would not surprise me drafting a
quarterback would not surprise me i
think that they'll be talking to
everyone you know you you probably have
your doubts about whether or not the
49ers would trade jimmy garoppolo within
the division but virtually everything
else i would anticipate seattle is
examining everything because you know
there's not a firm starter there fair to
say they like drew lock they think he
can develop they are interested to see
him compete for the job but if something
else presents itself i wouldn't stop
i wouldn't think that would stop john
schneider or pete carroll from doing
what they want to do a few minutes left
with tom pelicero my colleague from uh
nfl network nfl media group here on the
rich eisen show so you you referenced
matt ryan moments ago what is the deal
with him um i just
that's the opener um let me put a couple
more meat on the bone here because
you know the difference between him and
baker mayfield is there there's many of
them uh he never he didn't send out a
message to atlanta even though this is
the second straight year the falcons
were kicking tires either on a fourth
overall selection to replace him or
deshawn watson and so what's going on
with him with a roster bonus money and
the feasibility of him staying or the
the cost of him leaving what's the deal
with matt ryan
well the
falcons have been having trade talks
involving matt ryan since before
they found out that they were out on
desean watson and there certainly was a
point in time where the falcons thought
that watson was going to be coming to
atlanta uh there have been multiple
teams engaged the colts being a
significant one
that have been
talking for several days now you have to
get to a price point you also have to
work something out contract wise because
matt ryan's got two years 54 million
left no guaranteed money um he changed
agents recently you would anticipate
that a contract would need to be a part
of any deal but matt ryan's in a spot
where yeah he's been the quarterback for
14 years in atlanta he's won an mvp and
here the falcons are going after uh
somebody else you know it it certainly
casts doubt on his future uh it does not
sound like matt ryan was particularly
pleased the team did loop him in but he
was not pleased about those uh you know
trade talks with watson and so exploring
other things including us a potential
landing in indianapolis makes perfect
sense okay and the plan b you mentioned
for the saints is jameis that's the plan
b for the saints
it certainly sounds that way again i
wouldn't take anything off the table
they still say some hill they have ian
booker they drafted last year but you
know if james is going to land one spot
now a chance to start new orleans is it
and what about carolina what's their
plan b
tom
with carolina they still got sam darnold
who's fully guaranteed like 18 million
dollars this season so that's your
starting point um you know they they
weren't hard on desean watson for a year
and a half you know going all the way
back to last year they made about five
or six different pushes were not able to
um you know make a deal
for him so again they're a team that's
in a position of you've already got one
quarterback you're paying money to do
you add a second they don't have a ton
of picks because of all the trades
they've made you uh put out additional
draft capital are you better off with
the marcus mariota
they were really hopeful that they were
going to be able to land to sean watson
it didn't happen and so they're kind of
another team that's resetting here and
figuring out what they want to do and
let's say if the colts are successful in
getting matt ryan right then then what
would the falcons plan b be would they
go for baker is it possible baker winds
up without a starting seat this year if
the colts go with matt ryan do you think
tom
it's it's definitely possible i mean
because you just don't have any starting
spots left you know that's always the
issue when you're talking about
quarterbacks who become available
at this time of year now i would think
what baker wants is to go someplace
where elise has a chance to compete and
i would not think anybody is taking on
18.8 million to have him not be the
starter again if the browns eat a good
chunk of that could they get some value
baker goes someplace where it's not a
clear starting job that's that's
definitely possible too um there's just
there's a bunch of guys i mean look at
the number of high picks we're talking
about here baker was the number one
overall pick jameis was the number one
marcus mariota was number two cam newton
was a number one overall pick who we
haven't even mentioned and it's probably
not going to be starting somewhere but
could easily be within the league this
year matt ryan was a number three
overall pick i mean that's a lot of you
know we're talking about prime names and
and prime quarterbacks here and there's
just not going to be a spot for all of
them to be starting in the nfl tom
you're the man great work thanks again
uh look for my call i'd love to have you
on again thanks again appreciate it love
to do it rich thank you you got it at
tom pelicero you should follow him i
should i do
it's been dynamite
dynamite
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here